si j'en juge le budget et pour 2018 on
est encore loin d'un budget de
transformation la réalité pour l'état
c'est un déficit budgétaire qui continue
à croître
je dis pas que c'est simple de le
réduire c'est 195 milliards que nous
allons devoir emprunter sur les marchés
financiers au long de l'année
j'allais vivre heureusement qu'à la
sécurité sociale et les collectivités
territoriales pour moi dépenser parce
que nous voyons que la diminution de la
dépense publique ne met pas en marche en
même temps il ya des des réformes il ya
des signaux il ya des signaux qui sont
aussi des avancées les quelques poches
la baisse d'un certain nombre de
prélèvements obligatoires mais comme on
était record d'europe
on a encore une marge de progrès on peut
s'arrêter parce que là il faut détailler
si on parle de la baisse effectivement
des impôts oui mais en même temps on a 5
milliards de cg on a 3 milliards 4
d'impôt de fiscalité il ya des choses je
pense à l'impôt forfaitaire sur les
revenus du capital
la baisse du taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés
la suppression partielle de l'usf crois
qu'on aurait mieux fait de le supprimer
totalement
voilà des chiots qui sont de l'interview
mais la fin de la sf par exemple
arrêtons nous quelques minutes sur ce
point là vous savez bien ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on va vous reprocher ce qu'on va
vous dire à la droite pourquoi est ce
que vous l'avez pas fait avant et ce
qu'est ce que c'est pas un peu trop
facile de reprocher maintenant à
emmanuel macron ne pas faire ce que
feint de de faire à moitié les choses
que vous n'avez pas fait le tout avant
je reproche rien mais je ne suis pas se
nourrir vos rêves vous êtes dans la qui
revendique mieux la transformation pour
la transformation
il y avait dans les dents les projets
des candidats que nous soutenions la
suppression de l isf
c'est vrai que nous aurions pu le faire
avant on avait tenté de le faire
souvenez vous c'était il ya deux
décennies mais en tous les cas je crois
que le vrai sujet par exemple on avait
un engueuler la mort sur moins 120 mille
points est claire oui
pour cinq ans on commence petitement
1600 donc on a une marge encore 228 1400
dont 118 400 pardonnez-moi de cette
erreur de soustraction je crois qu'il
faut qu'on soit attentif à rend plus
compétitifs nos entreprises est vraiment
à maîtriser nos dépenses publiques mais
quand même est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que par rapport au quinquennat
de françois hollande la france s'est
remise en marche et remise en route qui
a des réformes qui se font qu'une équipe
qui est au bonheur quelques pas dans ce
qui est qui et qui ont harcelé pendant
cinq ans et pardonnez moi le jeu j'ai
toujours dit du quinquennat de françois
hollande
et comme je respecte la fonction c'était
quand même un quinquennat pour rien pour
rien on n'aurait rien et qu'on n'a pas
reculé
je constate qu on avance un peu c'est
quand même parce que calé au fond quand
je dis dans mes propos jour je suis
réélu président du sénat qui m'importe
c'est l'état de mon pays si mes
entreprises jeudi mais en trouver
puisque je suis français les entreprises
de france vont mieux demain elle crée
plus de richesses pour qu'elles créent
l'emploi et comment je ne soutiendrai
pas ce qui m'apparaît être des pas dans
la bonne direction